[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 10 janvier
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv
60,18 le tour de l'actualité locale en
26 minutes les titres de cette édition
trappe s'engage dans la promotion du
circuit court en partenariat a été noué
avec un éleveur de houdan il
approvisionnera la ville en viande
bovine local qui sera servi dans
l'assiette est une centaine d'écoliers
reportage au sein de la cuisine centrale
trappistes elle se revendique première
commune des yvelines sans perturbateurs
endocriniens villepreux à concrétiser
cette volonté hier avec la signature
d'une charte
une démarche qui portent notamment sur
la restauration scolaire l'entretien des
espaces verts et agricoles et aussi vers
des achats plus responsable enfin ce
livre vient d'être publiée par deux
yvelinois aux éditions larousse le guide
de la santé globale
elle vous donne les clés pour avoir la
forme une méthode qui prend en compte le
bien-être physique et mental mais aussi
l'aspect émotionnel et social es les
deux auteurs sont nos invités tout de
suite un autre individu à un autre
invité pardon pas sur ce plateau mais en
direct depuis las vegas bonjour et
manioli car bonjour merci nous répondre
il est 9h en ce moment à las vegas 18
heures en france vous êtes le cio de sky
one portal votre start-up participe pour
la quatrième fois aux crs de las vegas
et ça ça va depuis mardi qu'il se
déroule à las vegas
c'est un grand salon bien sûr dédié aux
nouvelles technologies et vous y
présenter une solution immersif qui
s'apparente à un jeu vidéo si une
solution immersive dans le domaine de la
santé
c'est ça exactement fort de notre
expérience dans le secteur du
divertissement immersif
on a pas mal d'échos les dernières sur
le secteur des états unis on a utilisé
ces technologies ont semé de solutions
avec le pôle vertige équilibre de saint
quentin en yvelines pour proposer des
jeux sérieux qui vont aider à la
réducation motrices et au traitement des
troubles de l'équilibré alors c'est la
première fois que vous participez à la
quatrième fois pardon vous participez à
ce s à las vegas pourquoi c'est une date
que vous notez chaque année dans votre
agenda pourquoi il faut y être à ce
service alors
concrètement nous surtout pour trouver
des partenariats et c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois qu'on a réussi à des
contacts avec des prospections de salon
est différent différentes société ou
entité
on a toujours réussi à arriver à me dire
quelque chose qui était vraiment à ces
structures en l'année dernière notamment
sur divertissement on a noué des
contacts avec des personnes qu'ils ont
vraiment permis de décoller son secteur
cette année
ça tombait bien parce que la solution de
nouveaux heurts ou a pu être mise en
place a put je dirais lancée et
officialisé et donc on en profite aussi
pour certes on continue toujours avec
l'europe
par contre sur ce secteur médical on
sonde un petit peu cette boue et des
partenariats mondiale blank c'est
l'intérêt de ce type de salon c'est que
nous on a trouvé des contacts de corée
du sud avec des hôpitaux sont plus
qu'intéressé par là par le produit
et voilà on cherche vraiment ce type de
synergies de partenariat sur ce type
d'événement
d'ailleurs nous et pour ce cms un
partenariat je crois que la société
créative works et sa expliquez nous en
quoi consiste ce partenariat alors
crédit works c'est une et une grosse
société américaine sur tout ce qui est
parc d'attractions qui est habitué à
construire des 71 jeux laser ou les
salles de jeux ou les eskers prouve et
on a pu en fait grâce aux crs ont eu des
contacts avec le et faire en sorte que
distribuer notre produit mais aussi le
fabriqué aux états unis rejettent toute
la partie logistique approvisionnement
il enfonce le support et nous derrière
effectivement on apporte notre valeur
ajoutée sur produits dont le produit est
vraiment en train de décoller grâce à
eux sur ce secteur
dernière chose en 30 secondes depuis
mardi à quoi ressemblent vos journées
qui vous avez pu rencontrer sur ce crs
de las vegas sous le soleil de las vegas
on voudrait vraiment de tout le monde
on a vu des personnes sur la santé
évidemment intéressés donc sur des
personnes
qu on vraiment des troupes de équilibre
elle même des représentants d'hôpitaux
aussi on a rencontré des mentors alors
typiquement on utilise une technologie
qui a technologie du cake et techno des
années 90 on a rencontré la créatrice
l'inventrice du km qui est venu nous
voir et qui soutient notre démarche
d'ailleurs on a rencontré des gros
acteurs l'us airforce typiquement qui a
des problèmes de maintenance qui veut
nous solliciter pour traiter les
problèmes on va les augmenter
donc voilà c'est vraiment de tout c'est
très hétéroclite
et voilà mondialement avec tous ces
besoins sont différents et qui est qui
s'intéressent à ce qu'on peut produire
et vous y êtes présents jusqu'à demain
vendredi sur ce s merci emmanuel icare
je rappelle que vous êtes le sémillon et
de sky one portal cette start-up saint
quentinois ce qui est donc présente sur
ce crs de à las vegas en bref des
membres de la section de recherches de
la gendarmerie de vélizy villacoublay
dans le jura ils font partie des 130
gendarmes engagés dans les recherches du
mirage 2000d cet avion militaire a
disparu des écrans radars depuis
mercredi matin quelques débris ont été
retrouvés mais aucune trace pour le
moment à des deux membres d'équipage
présents à bord on revient dans les
yvelines toujours plus de circuits
courts ou rattrape en ce début d'année
2010 9 la commune a décidé de se fournir
chez un producteur yvelinois la ferme du
moulin à eau dans l'exploitation produit
est de la viande limousine près de 2000
trappistes en tout vont pouvoir goûter
cette viande bovine le sujet à de
mélanie pocus vendredi 11 janvier dans
les assiettes des échos les trappistes
burritos dénoncé de boeuf aux oignons la
viande et yvelinoise l'adil travail avec
la ferme du moulin situé à autant c'est
la différence entre la production qu'on
avait avant et salles là la production
qu'on avait avant on connaissait
l'alimentation des animaux mais on ne
savait pas d'où venait l'animal et
pouvait venir de l'autre bout de la
france ou même peut-être d'ailleurs
parce que je n'étais pas limiter qu'à la
france un seul intermédiaire dans ce
circuit l'abattoir la viande limousine
est conditionnée sous vide dans les
prochaines semaines deux autres services
sont prévues dans les écoles et un au
self du
personnel communal l'homme de foi nous
sommes sur 230 kg pour un sauté de 110
kg pour un émincé et 160 kg pour du rôti
là-dessus s'ajoutent les 35 kg
d'entrecôte que nous allons servir au
restaurant du personnel communal ce qui
représente à peu près la totalité des
trois bêtes que nous avons acheté leur
mac consulter au mois de juin en disant
qu'il avait des bêtes à vendre et que il
aimerait bien en faire profiter les
collectivités le projet était très
intéressant près de 2000 personnes vont
déguster cette viande mois de janvier
les produits représente une trentaine de
centimes par assiette la ville
n'applique pas de changement de tarif
lutter contre les perturbateurs
endocriniens et leurs effets néfastes
sur la santé c'est l'objet d'une charte
signée hier par à villepreux parmi les
engagements une restauration plus
qualitative ou encore l'interdiction
deux produits phytosanitaires les
précisions d'aurélie ronge les images de
nicolas landry avec cette signature
villepreux devient la première ville des
yvelines à s'engager officiellement
contre les perturbateurs endocriniens
ces substances chimiques qui comme leurs
noms l'indiquent perturbe notre système
hormonal sont partout alimentation
cosmétiques et produits du quotidien à
villepreux
depuis le 1er janvier 2019 la
restauration pour les enfants et les
seniors et bio en 2015 la commune avait
également éliminé les produits
phytosanitaires pour l'entretien des
espaces verts
on a une politique extrêmement clair
c'est inclus réintégrer l'environnement
la démarche environnementale dans
chacune de nos décisions c'est ce que
nous nous avions fait et la bonne
surprise c'est qu'aujourd'hui
eh ben on a pu signer cette charte ça
montre vraiment l'engagement de
villepreux des habitants et de l'équipe
municipale pour l'environnement cette
charte a été mise en place par
l'association réseau environnement santé
en france près de 200 communes l'ont
signée y compris la région ile de france
objectif réduire l'exposition de la
population aux perturbateurs
endocriniens et l'enjeu des
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est que
c'est des sons des expositions
de courte durée pendant une période
sensible de la grossesse ou la petite
enfance qui va induire des impacts
sanitaires chez l'enfant
mais chez le futur adulte et même jeu
les descendants la charte comprend
également un volet achats responsables
les citoyens doivent aussi être informés
tous les ans de l'avancement des
engagements pris par la commune on
continue de parler santé avec mes deux
invités valérie et olivier brenier
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous alors
vous êtes et binoy co auteur de ce livre
le guide de la santé globale s'est sorti
hier aux éditions larousse 372 pages
pour avoir une santé de fer l'ouvragé
donne des clés pour aller pas à pas vers
un mieux-être durable déjà sur le titre
santé globale cela veut dire que pour
avoir la forme c'est tout un tas de
critères de facteurs qui vont entrer en
ligne de compte
en fait ce qu'un environnantes c'est de
se dire que la santé on pense souvent la
santé physique mais c'est bien plus
large que ça et donc il ya des
interactions entre notre tête notre
corps notre coeur et donc la santé
globale basse et de travailler en fait
sur ces différents registres pour pour
un mieux-être et aussi ce qui est
important c'est aussi tout ce qui est la
relation avec son environnement avec les
autres personnes mais aussi
l'environnement au sens large
c'est-à-dire bien être dans sa peau
voilà aussi bien socialement avoir de
bonnes relations sociales ça ça joue
aussi énormément
oui donc c'est certain tout est est ce
qui est important c'est de prendre en
compte toutes ces interactions et de
faire en sorte que non seulement notre
corps ah et bien mais tous les autres
registres de la personne et le fait que
ce bien-être intérieur justement être
bien mentalement physiquement
socialement aussi jouent sur la santé ce
que c'est prouvé scientifiquement et
qu'il ya des études qui le montrent ah
oui non le livre en fête pour chaque
technique qui on le représente
il ya les études scientifiques qui vont
avec les gens peuvent aller les constats
d il ya le lien en fait pour les
regarder effectivement de toute façon on
dans ce livre il n'ya que des techniques
qui ont été prouvés scientifiquement sur
l'apport de la de leurs pratiques en
fait
mais d'ailleurs vous preniez de
métaphores qui est assez amusante mais
qui est parlante celle de là
la fuite d'eau quand on a une fuite
d'eau chez soi on ne va pas se contenter
d'éponger loca par terre il faut
rechercher d'où vient à la fuite les
origines de la fuite finalement c'est un
peu pareil que la santé quand on est
malade il faut pas se contenter juste de
soigner cette maladie il faut comprendre
pourquoi on est malade ils sont
actuellement parce que il y a une
origine aux problèmes à la maladie et
c'est pour ça que c'est important de
l'avoir dans sa globalité
parce que si on va juste soigner
l'organe on va pas comprendre et on va
le soigner momentanément mais pas
durablement et du coup main si on va pas
chercher après la cause
on va aller chercher cette source
inquiets l'origine du problème tout en
soignant l'organe mais trouvait aussi
l'origine du problème
et pourquoi proposer ce livre du coup
c'est qu'on n'a pas encore forcément les
bons réflexes on va se contenter
justement d'utiliser un médicament pour
soigner cette maladie on va pas aller
plus loin
oui voire même on a tendance à attendre
d'être malade pour agir au nom de la
santé globale c'est aussi une santé
préventive même prédictif quoi parce
qu'on sait détecter en si on est à
l'écouté de son corps on sait détecter
des signaux bien avant fait que des
problèmes puissent se produire
donc en fait si régulièrement on prend
soin les différents registres dont on a
parlé
finalement la maladie a peu de chances
de se produire et l'idée c'est vraiment
non seulement de de vivre longtemps mais
de vivre le plus longtemps possible en
pleine santé en pleine forme mais comme
vous le disiez avec un vrai bien-être
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le constat
c'est que les gens viennent nous voir
quand ils sont malades et c'est pour ça
qu'on a écrit ce livre aussi parce qu'en
fait on si c'est quand même dommage
d'arriver malades et du coup on a essayé
dans ce livre de transmettre tous les
gestes de santé que chacun peut
entretenir et ce qui est important aussi
c'est de chacun ce responsabilités face
à sa santé et c'est pas pour autant
tirer un trait sur les médecine
conventionnelle c'est à dire que c'est
on sait en complémentarité finalement
cet ouvrage exactement parce que ça
n'enlève à rien
les traitements allopathiques de la
médecine aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
énormément évolué mais aussi c'est nous
en complément aller travailler sur le
volet mot sionnel sur le volet social de
manière ajustements élargir la
possibilité à la personne de guérir
parce que elle ressent des émotions à
travers sa maladie et si elle va pas
aller les rencontrer
ça va être difficile pour elle si elle
est toujours dans la vision négative de
sa maladie qu'est-ce qu'on ait des trous
dans ce livre vous expliquez j'imagine
la démarche
il ya des clés aussi pour pour aller
mieux tout à fait donc il ya il ya dans
un premier temps à une compréhension de
ce qu'est la santé globale et des
ressources que notre corps donc c'est
important d'en prendre conscience et
après ma on va vers des différentes
techniques
donc il ya des choses qui sont entre
guillemets classiques comme des choses
dit alan la nutrition au sommeil à
l'exercice physique mais dans toute une
partie on va vers des techniques qui
sont un peu plus innovantes mais que la
personne peut pratiquer de façon
autonome en bonus il ya de la vidéo
également des pistes audio pour aller
plus loin dit vidéo qui accompagne les
personnes et puis ce qui est très
important c'est que en fait dans ce
livre il ya un parcours de santé
ça veut dire qu'en fait chaque personne
qui rencontre des difficultés que ce
soit physique émotionnel psychologique
et sociale elle va pouvoir faire un état
des lieux de sa santé et avec les
résultats cette année elle va pouvoir
suivre un parcours qui va l'accompagner
pour améliorer sa santé
en fait et pour préparer ce livre il m'a
dit vous êtes appuyé sur votre
expérience vous en tant que art
thérapeute et et thérapeute et vous en
tant que coach en entreprise vous avez
pu vous appuyez sur cette expérience
pour pour préparer ce livre à moi j'ai
été aussi à 25 ans infirmière avant je
travaillais beaucoup dans le milieu
médical et je trouvais effectivement
qu'il manquait ces accompagnements là et
c'est pour ça aussi que moi je me suis
tourné complètement aujourd'hui dans ces
accompagnements là et c'est vrai que
c'est une complémentarité parce que
olivier en entreprise ils voient aussi
la souffrance au travail d'ailleurs vous
expérimenter des techniques novatrices
sur sur la santé tout à l'heure devant
que l'on introduit de la méditation de
la psychologie énergétique de la
cohérence cardiaque dans des
accompagnements d'entreprise et ce qui
n'était pas possible il ya seulement
trois ans maintenant c'est tout à fait
possible donc être avec des comités de
direction est et on médite ensemble on
se projette ensemble en visualisation
sur sur un bien-être pour l'entreprise
pour les collaborateurs
donc moi je suis très optimiste parce
qu'en fait il ya beaucoup de choses qui
bougent il ya une vraie accélération
donc d'un côté on peut se dire voilà
dans le monde il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se dégrade en même temps il ya tous
ces mouvements qui qui font espérer
enfin c'est même plus que d'espoir ou a
concrètement des actions et des et des
mouvements de gens qui s'engagent en de
montner déjà la fin de cet entretien qui
sera en dédicace à la fin de la semaine
sur le territoire samedi à au furet du
nord à skywest dans le centre commercial
sqy ouest
merci a vous de me valérie et olivier
brault nico auteurs de l'appel du guide
de la santé globale c'est disponible aux
éditions larousse au prix de 17 euros 95
l'accès est empruntée chaque jour par
quelques cent mille aux automobilistes
l'engorgement de la nationale 118 est un
sujet de préoccupation en ile-de-france
depuis décembre et des travaux d'urgence
ont été lancés au niveau de sèvres
entraînant la neutralisation d'une voie
de circulation pour limiter les effets
du chantier la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse a annoncé une série de
mesures les détails avec ce sujet de nos
confrères de via grand paris c'est un
axe stratégique pour les automobilistes
la n118 est désormais en travaux au
niveau de sèvres direction boulogne
billancourt deux murs de soutènement
doivent être renforcés principe de
précaution une voie de circulation a été
fermée pour l'instant les franciliens
n'ont pas encore pris la mesure de
l'impact de cette voie supprimés sur la
118e pont de sèvres et pour l'instant
nous n'avons
de calendrier de réouverture donc je
demande un calendrier sur un calendrier
travaux pour limiter les embouteillages
la région a décidé de prendre une série
de mesures de ram de réserve seront
mobilisés sur le tramway t6 aux heures
de pointe
le bus sera aussi renforcée sur le
réseau fébus et ratp
objectif faciliter le rabattement vers
les gares des rer b et c est sur les
lignes n ai eu du transilien
autre mesure la région finance le
covoiturage pour les habitants et
salariés des hauts-de-seine des yvelines
et de l'essonne
jusqu'à la fin des travaux enfin valérie
pécresse encourage des entreprises à
réaménager les horaires de leurs
salariés ou encore à mettre en place le
télétravail tous les jours plus de
100000 automobilistes empruntent la
nationale 118 1 marylène yapi chinois
avec moi sur ce plateau bonsoir alors
vous êtes rendu hier mercredi soir aux
voeux de la ville de plaisir il se
dérouler hier qu'est ce qui s'est dit au
cours de ces 2 alors joséphine coleman
berger la maire de la ville a donné
rendez vous aux plaisirs roi au gymnase
nicholas l'air pour dresser un bilan de
l'année écoulée et faire un point sur
les projets 2010 9 à plaisir la ville et
marquer bien sûr par la fin des travaux
de la rd 30 inauguré au mois d'avril
l'un des chantiers les plus importants
des yvelines qui a permis de désengorger
le centre-ville les aménagements et
l'urbanisme c'est justement le grand
projet de 2019
car la ville engage une révision de son
plan local d'urbanisme qui démarre qui a
démarré avec saint quentin en yvelines
et qui nous permet et bien de concerter
auprès de la population pour justement
à voir tout ce respect du centre bourg
dont je vous parlais qui est à la fois
historique et en même temps de ces vingt
hectares qui risquent de se libérer
puisque l'hôpital sharks on fusionne
avec l'hôpital gérontologie et on se
retrouve avec une réflexion très
importante au niveau du centre-bourg qui
semble je dirais la volonté de la vie
bien sûr des élus mais surtout des
habitants qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
eux et comment on va construire avec eux
je crois quelque part c'est un mot qui
fait peur l'urbanisme on a l'impression
que on est dans un développement
je dirais de construction alors que je
les dis dans mon discours
on n'a pratiquement pas bougé du nombre
d'habitants depuis 2006 parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de décohabitation mais
l'urbanisme si aussi la protection de
deux notes de nos espaces verts ou qui
la protection de notre territoire
et puisque l'on parle travaux est ce que
le chantier du futur centre commercial
openskies avance oui et la mer annonce
l'inauguration d'ici la fin de l'année
autre point important de son discours la
mise en oeuvre d'une réflexion sur les
transports en commun avec le département
car les plaisirs oies sont insatisfaits
de l'offre actuelle est un appel à
trouver un médecin généraliste pour
enfin monter ce projet de maison de
santé auquel il ne manque plus qu'un
médecin référent que la ville peinent à
trouver enfin elle n'a pas oublié le
contexte actuel et s'est engagé à
rentrer dans la démarche de concertation
nationale voulu par le gouvernement
des cahiers de propositions pour la
france sont déjà installés sur les
collectivités et la mère se dit prête à
organiser des réunions si les plaisirs
warm demande
merci marylène pour ce point à tout à
l'heure pour le retour de votre émission
le 7-8 loisirs c'est après ce journal
pour la dernière fois cette semaine nous
faisons un bond en arrière retour en
2018 pour connaître les faits marquants
cette fois ci à d'octobre à décembre
dernier un voyage dans le temps signée
manon varaldo le mois d'octobre a débuté
avec la disparition d'un grand chanteur
charles aznavour est décédé le 1er
octobre inhumé au cimetière de montfort
l'amaury l'artiste repose dans le caveau
familial
ils étaient nombreux à lui faire un
dernier adieu c'est tout
jeunesse c'est un grand monsieur et la
génération d'un maman qu'il l'aimait
beaucoup
autre disparition d'une figure de la
télé philippe gildas est décédé le 28
octobre à l'âge de 82 ans
l'une de ses dernières apparitions
étaient sur tv 78 elle a fait t elle
cette année son quart de siècle la fête
des vendanges
elle est organisée à la ferme mousseau
le premier dimanche d'octobre par les
amis du passé d'elancourt depuis 25 ans
c'est une première dans l'histoire du
club de baseball les cougars de montigny
le bretonneux sont arrivés en finale
nationale du championnat de france de
division 1
rodolphe le meur leurs entraîneurs
étaient en plateau
ça fait 30 ans que le club existe on
fait en plus l'anniversaire 7 cette
année et ça tombe à point nommé
d'atteindre ce niveau d'être en finale
de ce championnat de division octobre
2018 pierre bédier s'en souviendra il a
été élu président de la fédération des
républicains des yvelines avec près de
59 % des suffrages face à alexandra
dublanche vice-présidente de la région
autre annonce en politique charline
avenel 40 ans a été nommée nouvelle
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
elle a d'ailleurs effectué son premier
déplacement le 6 novembre au collège les
molières des essarts le roi ce mois de
novembre est impacté par une forte
mobilisation qui ne vous a pas échappé
celle des gilet jaune
les français opposés à la hausse des
taxes sur les carburants ont bloqué le
pays notamment le samedi 17 novembre
depuis des années des années les
salaires ils sont bloqués ils sont gelés
mmi diminue alors aujourd'hui bas on
travaille on travaille toujours plus
mais c'est pour gagner moins
alors là du coup il y en a ras-le-bol
cette année marque également la fin du
centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale tout au long des commémorations
des yvelinois ont participé à des
opérations autour du souvenir de la
grande guerre
côté sport déjà couronné de quatre
titres de champion de france de tumbling
axel duriez a brillé au championnat du
monde par groupe d'âge 2018 organisé en
novembre à saint-pétersbourg ce jeune
des clayes-sous-bois est le premier
français à être titré champion du monde
de la discipline dans la catégorie 13 14
ans ne rien laisser passer fin novembre
un portail de signalement des violences
sexuelles
lancée au commissariat de guyancourt des
ministres et des secrétaires d'état
étaient présents pour l'occasion
quand vous êtes témoin d'un cambriolage
vous appelez la police ou la gendarmerie
quand vous avez connaissance d'une
violences sexistes et sexuelles votre
devoir de citoyen c'est d'appeler la
police ou la gendarmerie où désormais de
vous connecter à cette plate forme de
signalement des violences sexistes et
sexuelles et didier fischer a pris
officiellement le dimanche 9 décembre
ses nouvelles fonctions de maire de
coignières autre nomination jean noël
barrot nommé secrétaire général du modem
le 13 décembre la colère des lycéens
s'est fait entendre en ce mois de
décembre ils se sont mobilisés contre la
réforme du baccalauréat et de parcours
sup certaines mobilisations ont dégénéré
avec des heurts entre jeunes et forces
de l'ordre qui ont procédé à quatorze
interpellations
il faut bien faire la part des choses
entre les lycéens qui ont certaines
revendications et des individus qui
viennent et qui profitent de ces
rassemblements pour venir casser brûler
des véhicules et attaqué les forces de
l'ordre dans le cadre de l'aménagement
du futur quartier la gare de la ligne 18
50 ans est un dévoiement de la rd 91 est
prévu un projet qui inquiète un
collectif d'habitants de
voisins-le-bretonneux l'année s'est
achevée avec les festivités de noël
c'était la première édition du comptoir
de noël au domaine de madame elisabeth à
versailles le fait main est loin d'être
dépassée pour noël le do it yourself
était à la mode en cette fin d'année
partons direction la chine
à la tombée de la nuit des sculptures
lumineuses géantes illumine les jardins
du zoo de thoiry
à découvrir jusqu'au 10 mars
et puis la musique aussi fait partie de
l'histoire le musée d'archéologie
nationale de saint germain en laye
propose une visite spéciale au son du
silex ou encore est de la flûte
un rendez vous à découvrir chaque
premier dimanche du mois mélanie poquet
a suivi l'un d'entre eux coline et
anne-cécile sont des guides un peu
particulière leurs livres d'histoire est
rempli de notes de musique est long mais
ne public dans une visite musicale du
musée d'archéologie nationale
la musique étant l'un des universaux de
notre humanité redécouvrir les
collections avec le prisme de la musique
était plutôt intéressant sachant qu'on
est en plus quelques instruments sein de
notre musée et s'était du coup
l'occasion de se rencontrer d'échanger
et de partager autour de deux thèmes
communs qui sont la musique est aussi
finalement nos origines
pour ce nouveau projet le musée a fait
appel à l'ensemble calliopée un ensemble
d'artistes accueilli en résidence cette
visite musicale spécialement conçu pour
dialoguer avec les collections l'idée
c'est de reprendre ce fil conducteur de
respecter l'histoire que proposait que
raconte le musée mais de prendre la
thématique du monde sonore depuis les
pierres les silex depuis les flux
d'historique ce qui sont ici c'est un
miracle ou qu'elle soit là et de se
l'approprier pour se dire mais ça ce
sont mes origines chanteuse et
musicienne font découvrir des morceaux
oubliés mais garde en tête les grands
noms comme mozart ou de lui si je trouve
ça très intéressant très agréable à la
fois de pouvoir voir des vrais
instruments dans les vitrines
et puis d'écouter de la musique d'être
guidé comme ça parle par les flûtes
j'ai vraiment bien aimé c'est
extraordinaire on a vraiment rêver dans
différentes époques
c'était vraiment magnifique pour moi
une visite originale qui s'inscrit dans
le programme c'est mon patrimoine à
découvrir qu'on soit mélomanes curieux
chaque premier dimanche du mois
et notez que ces visites sont suivies
d'un atelier sonore avec une chanteuse
et pédagogue de la voix c'est la fin de
ce journal belle soirée à tous avec tv
[Musique]